you have to study your craft I dedicated
myself to my craft perfect yourself
because they keep it
hello believe nation today we're gonna
talk about how you can master your craft
as you guys watch the video there's
something that someone says that really
hits you hard make sure to write it in
the comments below and leave it in
quotes so that other people can enjoy as
well boy this is the first time in years
do this all for amendments it's hard to
remember an old computer language I not
only designed this every little metal
trace that you see on here I strapped on
onto a drafting table and I built this
whole board myself because I wanted the
chips in the ultimate perfect position I
worked for a couple of weeks every night
till about 4:00 in the morning laying
out the little things on a big drafting
table that would eventually become this
board and when I got done I realized I
had to drill eight holes in the board
and I said you know what if I had only
designed it a little bit differently
then I would have only had five holes I
tore apart my entire design and for
another two weeks every night till 4:00
in the morning to get it just that
perfect with only five holes so you
would never see the freakness that it
had to be that artistically perfect to
me because it represents yourself when
you do something when you do a great
design
if you're really going to get ahead you
have to study your craft you have to
deeply study you know I I decided what
was it now 18 years ago that I wanted to
help inspire and motivate people and I
wanted to coach people one-on-one on
motivation on high performance and I
wanted to write books on the topics so
eighteen years ago I started reading a
book a week on psychology leadership
communication marketing and there.good
on my hand about human behavior and high
performance I was studying everything I
could in a psychology every single week
now it's like people like wait you've
read a book a week for 17 years I don't
brag about I'm not like oh yeah I look
at me that was for my passion I knew if
I really wanted to succeed at something
I had to study it and I had to study it
deeply and I couldn't you know spend all
this time doing all of things so I had
to study my craft the great artists of
our past history that's what they did
they did one thing they had a true level
of depth of study in that area now maybe
they dabbled in some other areas too but
they became famous because they studied
one area and so what's your area what's
what's the thing you need to study on
develop a deep level of competence into
how to do it and how that world works
because you know we have a saying in
Montana that the time to have the map is
before you enter the woods but a lot of
people have a dream and they run out
into the woods and they just start
trying stuff and they take this path and
this path and this path and this path
and because they didn't study best
practices they sundae with one don't you
know that they wake up and they're lost
they're
about who they are and where they're at
and they're in this dark forest of the
unknown with no plan to get out they had
no idea they just jumped into something
they didn't study before taking that
leap and I would say you know what study
pay attention learn from the best model
and most intelligent smart successful
people you can in any given area that
you want to succeed in in your life
before you get into it then develop
competency by doing it over and over and
over and over again don't do it once in
a while here and there over and over and
over that's how you get competence
I've never particularly been asked to do
transformations but you know you just go
you just get it in your head then you
just go I need to that's that's what I
need to do I don't know how to play that
part without looking that way I always
talked with the director about it it's
just that they don't necessarily
understand quite to what lengths I might
be talking about I feel if I work hard I
can play hard this is me did nobody get
in there and put the gloves on for me
did nobody go out there on that road and
run miles and miles for me nobody took
the broken ribs nobody took the bloody
nose I did it on I dedicated myself to
my craft and I busted my ass I'm gonna
take you to keep believing my skills
keep listening to my father keep
listening to my uncle and sit on his
throne for thirty months
my father worked two jobs his whole life
when I was at a gym gym for 30 years and
then he had a trash hauling service so
he had we had he had his own truck and
we would go door-to-door pick up
people's trash and it was one situation
where it was probably seven below zero
and very cold Saturday morning and my
job was to pick up all the loose trash
and so we it was so cold that I got
everything that I could just grab throw
it on the truck and I ran to the to the
truck because it was just cold to jump
in by the time I got in and the door
shut my father opened it back up
grabbed me and drag
through the snow back to the barrels to
say son you did a halfway job and if you
do this job in a half way manner you're
gonna be a half way basketball player
you put in half the time
you only put in half the time as a
student and he said you're supposed to
do this job right so I want you to go
get that several and I want you to chop
the ice until you can get all the trash
that's trapped in the ice and put it on
the truck and that's that's what
happened and so he taught me how to be a
perfectionist and do everything I just
worked my ass off in my room and kept
writing just recording I wasn't great
going into
by the time I got out of college
outliers
[Applause]
this book examine sees that one takes
his place says it's not about which the
world is not about the tablet dish of
water with it's about the habits in that
time and he says that around if you
might be master whatever it is that you
love to do if you want to craft
textually what you have to do is work
you have to learn a lot
you have the power Z says that if you
put in around 10,000 hours it's an
Master
what struck us most about Michael when
we met him all those years ago was his
dedication to the long hours in the pool
it's one reason why we trained seven
days a week while we trained during
Christmas while trying Thanksgiving 365
days a year however many clubs are
trained seven days a week so that gives
you one extra set training session every
single week where you can pick something
up so I mean I'm getting 52 more
practices than everybody else is and
that's kind of make that little or a big
difference in the end
I've thought many times about the advice
I might give a graduating class and I
can find no better quote than one that
was given some two hundred years ago by
a Polish general
Thaddeus Coast Cuzco who had come to the
United States to help Washington along
with Lafayette win our independence
he was an engineer fortified West Point
and was a major contributor to the
success of American arms he said shortly
after the war to a group of students
such as yourself said yourself to work
with reflection and intelligence either
at your prescribed duty carried out in
the most scrupulous manner or perfects
yourself in some science in which you
should have true mastery perhaps in a
shortened version General Colin Powell
summed it up find yourself something
you're good at and do it to perfection
something you enjoy and if you do that I
can promise you as I have over the past
thirty some-odd years you won't feel
that you've gone to work a day in your
life this
goddess of weather singer writer
producer composer choreographer you got
to perfect that craft learn the business
and people always forget you're in a
music business understand how these
contracts read get the right people
management support system and attorneys
no way as you're getting into before you
sign anything thank you guys so much for
watching I hope you enjoyed I love to
know what you thought of the video which
clip moved to the most how are you
mastering your craft leaving the
comments below and I will join in the
discussion I also want to give a quick
shout out to Mel Mel Mel Mel thank you
so much for picking up a cop in my book
really means a lot to me those are you
watching if you want to change at a
shadow in a future video make sure to
grab a copy of the book and email in
your seat so we can keep track thank you
guys so much for watching
continue to believe or whatever your one
word is and I'll see you soon